اتسع نطاق المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم ومناطق
اخرى مخلفا مزيدا من القتلى والجرحى وصف
رفضا من الطرفين لاي حوار لا لانهاء
القتال بينهما
ومع تصاعد القلق الدولي والتحركات
الدبلوماسيه بشان هذه التطورات عقد مجلس
السلم والامن الافريقي جلستين طريقتين
لمناقشه التطورات في السودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي الاسباب
الحقيقيه وابعاد القتال واقتتال الخلاف
بين انتقال الخلاف بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع الى مرحله المواجهات
المسلحه من اجل السيطره على المواقع
والمقر الحيويه في الخرطوم وفي عدد من
المدن السودانيه
وكيف بدت مواقف اطراف الازمه في السودان
من هذه المواجهات المسلحه بين الجيش وقوه
دعم السريع واي انعكاسات لما قد تؤول اليه
على توازنات القائمه في البلاد
وما الذي بوسع القوى الاقليميه والدوليه
الراعيه لجهود السلام في السودان ماذا
بوسعها ان تفعل من اجل انهاء الاقتتال في
السودان والتمكين لاتفاق السلام كي تخرج
البلاد منه ازمتها
[موسيقى]
وكان الاتحاد الافريقي قدع المجتمع
الدوليه الى دعم مبادره الاتحاد لوقف
القتال وارساء الهدوء في السودان وفي ظل
تحركات دبلوماسيه تتعلق بتطورات الوضع في
السودان دعم مجلس الامن الدولي الى وقف
القتال واستعاده الامن وحتى اطراف النزاع
على العوده الى الحوار لحل الازمه الحاليه
في السودان
في داخل السوداني قال قيادي في قوى الحريه
والتغيير
المجلس المركزي قال ان على البرهان وحميتي
ان لا ينظر الى مصالحهم الشخصيه وان يجلس
في حوار للتوصل الى حلول تجنب السودان
الحرب الاهليه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم الدكتور معتصم عبد القادر الحسن
المستشار بالاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه وينضم الينا ايضا
من الخرطوم الدكتور موسى خدام محمد مستشار
قائد قوات الدعم السريع ومن واشنطن عبر
الهاتف ديفيتشن مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق لشؤون افريقيا نرحب بكم
جميعا ضيوفا في هذه الحلقه وابدا من
الخرطوم مع الدكتور معتصم عبد القادر
الحسن ما الذي اوصل الامور الى هذا الحد
من الصدام والاحتقان والاشتباك والمعارك
لك الشكر والتحيه والتحيه
الكريمين والتحيه للساده القناتي الجزيره
اولا اذا عملنا قليلا من المسائل السياسيه
الى مرحله ما قبل 25 اكتوبر 20 21 في تلك
الفتره قوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المجلس والكتله الديمقراطيه
نعم قوه حمدوك ولكن نتيجه للانسداد
السياسي ونتيجه لمحاولات
وعدم التعاون معها في حكم البلاد اضطر
السيد القائد العام القوات المسلحه اصدار
اجراءات 25 اكتوبر ومن بعد ذلك
ذهبت الكتله الديمقراطيه
حكم السودان اما
المجلس المركزي للحريه والتغيير
اي شقه صف المكون العسكري واستعمال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع في ذلك الوقت الدعم
السريعه المتمرده الان على الجيش السوداني
حاولوا اغرائه بان بامكانه حكم السودان
لوحده متحالفا مع المجلس المركزي الحريه
والتغيير وبذلك صار يعمل ويتحرك ويحرك
قواته وفقا لهواه وبعيدا عن القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه مما حدث
تضاربا في الموقف العسكري داخل السودان
وجعل للسودان جيشين بدلا ان يكون هنالك
جيشا واحدا وهذه المسائل في غايه الحساسيه
بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه مما
عدته تمردا على الجيش الوطني وبذلك
وبعد ذلك
بحجز قوات من شمال دارفور داخل الخرطوم
وكذلك حرك قوات من الخرطوم الى شمال
السودان في مطار مروي موسى ما هي مهام قوه
الدعم السريع اذا كانت اذا كان للدوله جيش
يقوم بالمهام المنوطه به لماذا توجد قوات
اخرى وجيش اخر
في كل العالم ان هناك وحدات
في المهام مختلفه الدعم السريع له مهام
واختصاصات منصوص عليها في القانون لا لا
نستطيع تعدادها او يعني
ذكرها الان ولكنها كثيره جدا والا لم يكن
هناك يعني جدوى او دعوه
لانشاء مثلها كذا قوات قوات الدعم السريع
كما ذكرت في بدايه حديثي
وطنيه خالصه ولها مهام اختصاصات الان لها
مساهمات كبيره جدا من مجتمع السوداني في
حمايه الوطن وامن المواطن والحد من الهجره
اذا اذا كانت مهامها الحفاظ اذا كان مهام
مهام هذه القوات والحفاظ على الوطن
والحفاظ على المواطن ماذا يفعل الجيش
جزء من الجيش ومسانده له واحده من مهامه
للجيش في حمايه الامن الوطني والمواطن
لذلك
ولم يكن هناك قانون ليلقي يعني هذا
الانشاء برهامي بمزاجه او غيره من من
هذا هذا هذه القوه يكونوا يعني مقتين
هو ايضا اذا اذا قدمت لم يتم
انت مساعد وزير خارجيه الامريكي السابق
للشؤون افريقيا وتعرف القاره ومشاكلها
والسودان تحديدا كيف تتابع ما يجري في
السودان
انما يجري في الوقت الحاضر هو امر كارثي
للاسف لشعب السودان وهذا ادى الى انهيار
في السلطه والصلاحيات هناك كفاح على
السلطه يجري الان بين عنصرين من الجيش
وبنايه الامر قد يكون هناك فائز عسكري
ولكن لن يكون هناك فائز حقيقي بغض النظر
عما سينتصر عسكريا لان الشعب السوداني هو
من سيعاني صحيح القول ان اغلبيه الدول في
العالم لديها جيش واحد وليس جيشين ربما
باستثناء ليبيا ولكن في العاده يكون هناك
جيش واحد ومؤسس عسكريه واحده في حاله
السودان كان هناك اثنان الفكره هي ان يكون
هناك عمليه دمج لقوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش السوداني
ولكن النقاشات انهارت بشان الاطار الزمني
للقيام بذلك وقوات الدعم السريع
تريد عشره اعوام لاعاده الدمج بينما الجيش
قال نريد عامين هذا كان قبل بضعه اسابيع
والنتيجه ما نراه الان يتجلى امامنا وهو
انهيار كامل في الثقه بين الجيشين
والمكونين للقوات العسكريه طيب دكتور
معتصم عبد القادر الحسن اعود الى كلام
دكتور موسى وكان يقول انه قوات الدعم
السريع هي رسميا
وقانونيا هي جزء من المؤسسه العسكريه من
من الجيش الا يبدو هذا الكلام غريبا يعني
في هذه الحاله ما هي مطالب كل طرف من
الطرفين
قانون الدعم على السريع في الماده سته ينص
على ان القوات المسلحه فان قوات الدعم
السريع التي صارت العامه السريع جزء من
القوات المسلحه ولكن هي لم تلتزم بهذه
المساله هي تسمى قوات الدعم السريعه اسال
ضيفك الكريم ما هي العمليات التي
قامت هذه القوات بعد 2019 بعد التغيير نعم
استخدمها البشير في حربه مع حركات التمرد
في دارف ولكن ماذا حدث بعد ابريل 2017 هذه
القوات
ذهبت كيتاج في الذهب وكي تراكم في الثروات
وكيف تؤثر بها في العمل السياسي السوداني
وخرجت على طاعه القوات المسلحه
لا هذه مهمه القوات المسلحه هي قوه اجداد
قوه دعم من الاسم عند كونها البشير كونها
لدعمه دعم سريع
القوه سريعه تتدخل في المهام
لافضل اصابات وممارسه هذه الدوله ضد
المواطنين في دارفور وسببت النزوح واللجوء
الذي يحدث الان في دارفورد
وبعد ذلك ابداعت انها الى جانب الجماهير
ما جاءت تغيير في ابريل عام 2019 ولكن من
بعد ذلك هي اتخذت منحا استقلاليا من اجل
الوصول الى السلطه بصوره كامله وادعت انه
وروج لذلك بعض السياسيين الذين
استغلتهم الى جانبها
وجد الى انها يمكن ان تكون الجيل الاساسي
والجيش السوداني الذي له اكثر من 100 عام
خبره في العمل العسكري والامن على امن
واستقرار البلاد البلاد وفي تثبيت الامن
الداخلي ادعد انها يمكن ان تكون بديلا له
وان الجيش السوداني يمكن ان يكون جزءا
وبعد ذلك في قبل في قبل ايام حركت قوات من
شمال دارفورت وزجت بها اوسط المدنيين ووصل
المناطق السكنيه وكذلك
اسال الاسئله البسيطه هذا كله كان ايام
الصراع في دارفور وبالفعل استعان بها
الرئيس المعزول عمر حسن البشير بهذه
القوات وحدث ما حدث وانتهى وذهب البشير
وانتهت وانتهى عهده وبدا عهد جديد لماذا
لم تحل بعد الثوره اذا
كانت كانت هنالك كانت الفتره انتقاليه
وكان من ضمن شروط الانتقال ان تكون هنالك
اصلاحات
ومن اجل في القوات المسلحه ولكن ظلت
باستمرار ثمانيه وتعطل واتخذت مواقف
مستقله وصارت تستعين بالقوه السياسيه
وصارت تمثل جسمه مزدوجه جلما موازيا
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه وصارت هنالك
ازدواجيه وخلقت شكل من اشكال تعدد الجيوش
في السودان وعندما جاءت الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري صارت تتعلل بانها تحتاج الى اكثر
من عشره سنوات في حين انها هذه المساله
يمكن ان تتم بمرسوم دستوري من راس الدوله
ولكن القوات المسلحه اخص منها الى عدم
تصعيد الموقف اصدرت بيانات لتفجر الاوضاع
الاخيره لان هذه التصرفات التي تتصرفها
الى القضاء الاخضر واليابس في السودان
وهذا ما تحاول الكلام الى الدكتور موسى
خدامه محمد استمعت الى كلام دكتور معتصم
يعني انتهت مهامها قوه دعم سريع شكرا شكر
الله سعيكم وانتهى دورها ويفترض ان تتسلم
المهام الجيش وانتهى الاسناد وانتهى الدعم
الداعي لبقائها ماذا ما هدفها تهدف الى
ماذا في النهايه تريد ان تصل الى ماذا من
المضحك من المضحك جدا من المضحك جدا ضيفك
يعني انتهاء مهام هذه القوه كما ذكرته هي
منشيه منشيه بقانون
نفس السؤال الذي ساله ضيفك الكريم ماذا
قدمت القوات المسلحه منذ 2019 انا اقول له
القوات الدعم الحاجه للثوره من حاجه للصور
وان حازت الى الشارع السوداني
يعني محافظه على على التحول الديمقراطي
وعلى الفتره الانتقاليه هل هل هل
حررت قوات المسلحه الفشقه ام حررت حلايب
ام حررت حتى حتى يمتنع عن الشعب السوداني
هذا الضيف او الهارب انا اقول الهارب
البرهان لانه لم يعد الان هو غايد لقوات
الشعب المسلحه ولم يعد الان هو رئيس لمجلس
لذلك يؤكد لك ان هذه
ردا عليه المحافظه
دكتور معتصم ماذا على البرهان ان يفعل
الان بصفته القائد الاعلى او يعني باعلى
قائد سلطه في البلاد الان
البرهان
يعني هذا هذه المسائل يعني كما ظهر بالامس
قائد مليشيا الدعم السريع المتمرده
من بعد ذلك البرهان الان موجود في مقر
قيادته وبالامس كان يتجول ووسط جنوده وذهب
الى منطقه ام درمان وذهب الى منطقه الشجره
وذهب الى مناطق اخرى هو الان ما زاد قائ
السودانيه ويمسك بامام المبادره وقوه
الدعم السريع انتهت تماما
لماذا عليه ما الملوك به نعم السؤال هو
ملمنط بالبرهان ان يفعله الان
البطانه الان هو يحاول ان يجلب الشعب
السوداني ما قامت به قوات الدعم السريع من
هجوم على على القياده العامه للقوات
والهجوم
في المدينه الرياضيه الان البرتقال
يعمل عملا عسكري اي انهاء هذا التمرد هذا
التمرد عسكري لابد ان منهن كي نعود للقوات
الطبيعي ان يكون هنالك جيش واحد
تعود الاوضاع الى الوضع الطبيعي الطبيعي
كما كانت عليه ربما من قبل يجب ان تكون
هناك بساطات ضغوط دوليه ربما على هذا
الطرف او هذا الطرف او الطرفين معا كيف
يتعاطى برايي كيف ترى طريقه تعاطي المجتمع
الدولي مع هذا هذه المشكله او هذه الازمه
ان هناك حربا مستمره الان في البلاد
والتي نراها الان في البلد فمن المستحيل
تقريبا المجتمع الدولي او اي عنصر منها ان
ينهي هذا الامر وهذه الازمه لن يكون هناك
تدخل من القوات الدوليه في هذا الوضع ابدا
قد يكون هناك امكانيه لوضع ضغوط اقتصاديه
على الجانبين
واشير هنا الى انه
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش هما الان
منخرطان في الاقتصاد السوداني بعمق وهناك
مؤسسات زراعيه ومصالح بنكيه والسودان ايضا
لديه الكثير من
البنوك وشركات التصنيع هي تابعه للجيش
لذلك العنصران والجيشان لا يريدان التخلي
عن هذه المصالح اذا من الصعب بالتالي ان
يكون هناك تدخل ذو نفوذ من الخارج ضدهما
ما لم يتم هذا من خلال ممارسه الضغوط
الماليه لكل هذه الدول التي لها مصالح في
السودان وخاصه دول الخليج اذا مصالح
اقتصاديه تقف ايضا وراء هذا المشهد
دكتور موسى خدم محمد عروض الوساطه لا نقول
الوساطه لانه لم تبدا حتى الان ايه وساطه
هناك عرض من مصر هناك عرض من جنوب افريقيا
هناك مسائل الاتحاد الافريقي هناك نيه
لرئيسه الاتحاد الافريقي للتوجه الى
الخرطوم رغم انه المطار مطار الخرطوم
الدولي ما زال مغلقا هل
هناك تعويل فعلا على الوساطات هي حل هذه
الازمه
مرحب مجددا اولا ننبهك يعني المفروض الفرص
توزع بعداله انا لا يمكن فكرتي في البدايه
انا افتكر من المبكر جدا يعني
اي عمليه تساطه في هذه المرحله افتكر لم
تنجح في هذه الظروف الحرجه ضيفك يدعي ان
البرهان يريد حقن دماء ابناء السودان اذا
كان فعلا هو يريد حقنه دماء ابناء السودان
عليه بالتخلي عن الهروب وتسليم نفسه فورا
وعاجلا هذا هو الذي يؤدي الى حقنه دماء
ابناء السودان لانه هو لم يحارب
بالجيش السوداني الوطني الخالص هو الان
يحارب بمعاونه افراد من النظام الثابت من
كتائب الظل والدفاع الشعبي والمجاهدين وهم
الان في قبضه قواتنا الباسله لذلك عليه ان
يستسلم حتى يجنب البلد من هذه المهالك نحن
نرحب
بالوساطات وبكل المبادرات ولكن الوقت
مازال مبكرا حتى
لا نمانع في الجلوس مع اي جهه والاستماع
لها والاستماع الى
الكريم يدعي بانه قوات الدعم السريع
ومتمرده انا اقول الان هو البرهان المتمرد
هو احوال البرهان مثل هذا الضيف الذي
يتحدث
يعني انقلابيين حقا لانهم ارادوا ان
ينبغيوا هناك انقلاب يعني مح
كم لانه
يسعون الى الى الى اعاده عناصر النظام
السابق من العسكرين ومن من من من كتائب
الظل وغيرها من
المتخلفين لذلك ندعو البرهان مجددا لتكريم
نفسه حتى يجنب البلاد هذا هذا الخطر
الماسي لاوام الناس ان شاء الله في
الاخبار العاجله الان نقلا عن الرئاسه
الكينيه منظمه ايجاد
تقرر ايفاد رؤساء كل من كينيا وجنوب
السودان وجيبوتي الى الخرطوم
لمحاوله التوسط من اجل حل هذه القضيه هذا
هذه الازمه الدكتور معتصم عبد القادر
الحسن ماذا يمكن ان تفضي اليه جهود منظمه
انا اعتقد ان استمرت عمليه الدعم السريع
انتهى الان وكل القواعد بعضها وطبعا وصار
يحارب الى جانب الجيش السوداني والان سوف
تشاهدين هذه المسائل الان اذا تابعت وسائل
الاعلام يجب علينا موضوع قاعده مروي شمال
السوداني انتهى هنالك بعض الجيوب في
الخرطوم عندما ننتهي من تنتهي القوات
المسلحه من هذه الجيوب وتعيد الذي دعم
السريع الى حضن القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وتحاكم الذين تسبب في هذه المساله من
قادتها ومن معاونها انا اعتقد عندها وهذه
المثال لن تاخذ وقتا طويلا انا اعتقد
عندها
الشعب السوداني لن يحتاج الى اي شكل من
اشكال
السوداني حكومه سودانيه ترحب باي شكل من
اشكال حقن دماء السودانيين وترحب بالرؤساء
الافارقه الذين ياتون من اي حقن هذه
الدماء ولكن انا ان المساله انتهت وانما
يسمى الدعم السريع انتهت اذا كنت انا اعلم
انك لا تصالحين الاخبار بصوره جيده الان
هذه المسائل انتهت هذه
الان هو تطهير وتنشيط ومحاولات
لتلبس هذه العداله وانا اعتقد ان هذه
لم يكن
اليومين القادمين هذه المسائل المرصوده
الان انا اعتقد لن يبقى كثير
للدول الخارجيه كي تفعله في امر الشان
السوداني لانهم عندما ياتون سوف يجدون ان
القوات شكرا لك نكتفي بهذا القدر انتهى
وقت البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور موسى
خدام محمد مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع
من الخرطوم وشكرا للدكتور معتصم عبد
القادر الحسن المستشار بالاكاديميه العليا
لدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه ومن واشنطن
ديفي مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق لشؤون افريقيا شكرا لكم جميعا
وبهذا ينتهي ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب
المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]